لكم
بالنيابه عن ميلانيا ونفسي واسرتي اشكركم
جميعا على حضوركم الليله لهذه المناسبه
الخاصه في هذا المكان الخاص
ان هذه الحركه في اعظم الدول في تاريخ
العالم هذه مساله بسيطه جدا
هذا التحرك
ولم يكن مثله ولن يكون مثله في المستقبل
[تصفيق]
ضيوف الكرام
العوده الامريكيه ستبدا الان
[تصفيق]
صبي كانت الولايات المتحده مستعده حينها
لعصرها الذهبي في مكانها
والقضاء على كل الاعداء وخطوه واثقه نحو
المستقبل بقوه
افريقيا
من شباب وكبار
ومن اصول
مختلفه واعرق مختلفه في الولايات المتحده
وما من امر
يظهره وما مر علينا وقت كهذا
رفعنا
الملايين من
الفقر وكذلك عندما ضربات الجائحه قال
الولايات المتحده اتخذنا خطوات وفي اكتوبر
من نفس العام كانت الولايات المتحده تعود
باسرع انت عشان اقتصادي سجل في التاريخ
فماذا عن ذلك
[موسيقى]
كل الادارات
القادمه ما كان عليها هو ان تستريح وتراقب
التضخم لم يكن موجودا
وحدودنا كانت الاقوى بسبب
تضييق الحدود
في اقل معدلاته من سنوات طويله
والولايات المتحده حققت الحلم
المستحيل للاستقرار الاستقلال
في الطاقه وتمكنت من الهيمنه في الطاقه
ايضا
لابسين ادراجها ولم نرى ذلك من قبل فقامت
الولايات المتحده بكل خطوات الممكنه
وتدفى الصين
من الضرائب ولكن
ما من احد سبقني في ذلك وان يحصل الرئيس
على دخل من الصين الى ان اتيت انا الى
المنصب وقمنا بدور فاعل في انتخابات في
انتخابات 20 20
بارك الله فيك
في الصين الان بداوا في وقتي بداوه في
العوده الى فرص العمل على ارض امريكا
وكانت هناك
الاعفاءات الاكبر في التاريخ اكثر مما
تمكن من تحقيقه رونالدو
يتصرفون باحترام شديد للولايات المتحده
ويحترموني انا شخصيا لانهم يعرفونني جيدا
والخلافه الخلافه داج التي لم يتمكن رئيس
من هزيمتها انا من فككتها ومحاربيه
الرائعين خلال اسابيع
وكذلك تم قتل البغدادي كوريا الشماليه لم
تطلق
صاروخ طويل الامد منذ القمه مع
الرئيس
وطورنا هذه العلاقه وهذه مساله جيده وليست
بسيئه بل هي جيده جدا
صوروني على انني
محب للحرب ولكن
لو انهم اصبحوا رؤساء لنرى حربا ولكن منذ
تولي الاخرين الرئاسه نرى هذه الحروب وانا
كنت من تمكن من وقف الحروب لفتره طويله
[تصفيق]
وامريكا تزدهر وعلى مسارها نحو مستقبل
باهر
الامريكي وعلى النقيب من اي رئيس سابق
فانا وفيته بكل هذه الوعود
[تصفيق]
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
وعظيمه وهذا امر لم تسمعوا به لمده طويله
كلنا امه قويه وكذلك حره لكننا الان
فقط
واسعار الغاز الاعلى في التاريخ
ومتوقع ان ترتفع اكثر بسبب ان الاحتياطي
الذي ملاته انا همم
سلم استقلالنا في الطاقه وتخلى عنه ولا
والان
نسعى لان نحصل على الطاقه من
دول العالم وقد
ايضا اخترقت حدودنا من الملايين من من
اتوا لاسباب
سيئه
ندفع ثمن هذا الغزو على اراضينا علامات
سنوات القادمه
المخدرات الفتاكه وايضا
هناك جرائم العنف التي نراها في العالم
وهذا
ما وصفوه على انه حقيقه الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه وقد احرجنا واصبحنا اضعف امام
الاخرين
الكارثه في افغانستان ربما هي
اكثر لحظه محرجه في تاريخنا فقدنا ارواحا
وتركنا امريكيين وسلمنا
85 مليار دولار من
المعدل بقيمه قيمه المعدات التي تركناها
هناك
وهذا امر
[تصفيق]
حتى الديمقراطيين يعترفون بذلك وهم
اعترفوا به مرارا وتكرارا لكن اعداءنا
عنا
بالزراء وسخريه بسبب هاتين الوكاتين هناك
اكثر فاليوم صاروخ
باي باي يا باشا ربما الروسيه وقع على
الاراضي
البولنديه او على مقربه 50 ميل من الحدود
البولنديه وهناك
شديد
في مؤتمرات دوليه
حول افغانستان
ساده
ليتحدث في قمه المناخ
ويدعو تلك الدوله
في قاره مختلفه
يمكن ان نذكر الحرب النوويه الان هناك
حديث عنها
التي قد تؤثر علينا في 300 عام
على انه تهديد
الله اكبر
لكننا هنا اليوم
ان لنعلن انه ليس بالضروره ان يبقى الامر
على ما هو عليه
فقط
[تصفيق]
هذا الانتشار اليسار الذي يسعى الى تدمي
العظمه والمجد لامريكا
اسبوع تقريبا
[تصفيق]
وانا سعيد بان صوته هو الذي احدث الفرق
لكن قبل ساعه هناك كثير من الانتقاد على
ان الجمهوريين كناريم مفروض ان يكون
ادائهم افضل كثير من هذا الانتقاد صحيح
لكن على الجميع ان يدرك
قسوه الالم والمعاناه في هذه الامه فهم لا
يشعرون بها الان كثيرا لكنه
بحلول 2024
سنرى حقيقه ما حدث في همم بلدنا وسيكون
التصويت مختلف
20 24 هو الموعد
[تصفيق]
هل انتم مستعدون
وانا كذلك مستعد
انه في الانتخابات النصفيه
الامور بشكلها الامنيه الاعلام
هو انا
اداره اداره
الوضع في البلاد بالنسبه للارهاب الاسلامي
وكذلك تجديد
الاوضاع على الحدود
فلم يكن خلال فتره اداره ترامب لم يكن
هناك هجمات
لدينا علاقات طيبه كثير من الدول بما فيها
همم التواصل الى المعاهدات الابراهيميه
بناء الاقتصاد الاعظم
لم يكن هناك في التاريخ
كما كان قبل عامين لا يمكن ان نفقد الامل
دائما علينا ان نعمل جاهدين
شخص
الذي يحبه وسيكون
السيناتور الرائع
اعطوه صوتكم فهو يستحقه
كان رياضي متميز وسيكون كذلك كاسر هناك
مجموعه
من
الامريكيين المميزين
نتذكر ان الجمهوريين
خمسه مليون
اكبر
كبير جدا
[موسيقى]
هذه المساله مهمه جدا
همم
من الرجال والنساء تمكن همم
[تصفيق]
لا بد منك
دين
ستكونون بشكل جيد تم فصلها
من اجل انقاذ الحلم الامريكي
[موسيقى]
كلمتين كلمتين اثنتين الحلم الامريكي
افعل
فانا همم
رئيس الولايات المتحده في الجوله المقبله
شكرا لكم جميعا
[تصفيق]
وافراد العائله الرائعين مواقف
معي ودائما يسالونني كيف تتحدث امام كل
هذا الحشد بسهوله فكان ردي انك عندما ترى
كل هذا الحب فان الثلاثه ستنطلقوا نفسها
اكانتي
في وضع سيء وفي
مشكلات كثيره هذه
الثقه
والروح الامريكيه هذه حركه وليست لفرد
واحد
بل هي عمل من عشره لعشرات الملايين من
من الامريكيين من كل
الاصول
مع الاصول الاسبانيه
واصول الافريقيه والاسيويه وانا انظر الى
ما يحدث نحن هنا في حزب اصبح اقوى واكبر
واكبر قوه ويستطيع ان يفعل كل ما هو جيد
لهذه البلاد
5 5
عمال المطافي ولا اطباء والمزارعين
والعمال لا يستطيعون ان يبقوا صامتين انتم
غاضبين لما يحدث في بلادنا فقد دمرت امام
ناظرينكم
وكل شاب وكل اسره ولكل اصحاب عمل
وحتى
سيء هؤلاء رائعين وهم يعرفون كيف يوقفوا
الجريمه لابد ان نعيد لهم كرامتهم
واحترامهم
مايكل
بل هي حملتنا جميعا
[تصفيق]
هزيمه الفساد هو انتم والشعب الامريكي
الاعظم انا احبهم جميعا ولا احب كل
الاطراف واصل وحدهم وما يحدث
في الادارات السابقه
ظالميه ونبليفه
جدا
اتخيل ان يتحدث الي لكن فيما بعد اتى
فيروس الصين هذا الفيروس الذي وصلنا الا
اننا حاربناه وقمنا بعمل الرائع وعندما
يقولون جمهوريين وديمقراط
محافظين
لا يهم يجب ان نعمل معا
[تصفيق]
ي
في الصين
فعلنا انا كما قلت في 2016 انا صوتكم
مؤسسه واشنطن تريد ان تصمتنا لكننا لن
نسمح لهم بذلك ما بنيناه معا على مدى
سنوات السته الماضيه هو اكبر حركه ناجحه
فهو ليس بسياسه بل هو بدافع حبنا لهذه
الامه العظيمه امريكا ولن نخفق في ذلك
العالم لم يرى
الحقيقي لهذه الامه لم نصل الى ذلك بعد
ظريفه
مسافات خارقه لكن علينا ان نخرج من هذه
الكبوه
ومن بعد من بعد ذلك صدر نجاحا لم يكن له
ااا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السابقين
ليس علينا
هذه
بلدنا وحكومتنا
المسؤولين عن السلطه هم من يمثلوننا ونحن
ناتي الان لاستعاده تلك
[تصفيق]
القوه حتى يوم الانتخابات في 2020 الذي
سياتي السريعا لنرى كيف ستمضي الوقت بشكل
[موسيقى]
انواع كويس
نريد الحمايه
بشكل كبير وهذه المشكله الفساد
في واشنطن
وكان يدعوهم
ان كنت في مجموعه العشرين احب ذلك
الاجتماع كنت التقي بقياده العالم ولا تصل
نتوصل الى اتفاقات
ولنسمح لهم بان يستغلوا
وصلنا الى اتفاقات همم مع مكسيك وكندا
وكذلك
المزارعين
العمال
وكذلك رئيس الوزراء ابي
كان الصديق قديم
وهمم
افضل شيء هو ما قمنا به
الصين
والدمار الذي تسبب به في العالم
على اربع سنوات اضافيه
[تصفيق]
ان امتنا لا تستطيع ان تتحمل ذلك
بقلب محزون لان امتنا لا تستطيع ان تتحمل
اكثر فوصلنا بدرجه من الهشاشه
لاتينوفرز
على اصوات الاصول اللاتينيه والحسبانيه
كان
كانت نتائجنا رائعه
يريدون الحمايه
اعتقد الجميع انني ببناء الجدار ساخسر
هؤلاء لكن هم كانوا يفهمون مساله الجدار
اكثر من اي طرف اخر
ان سنواصل وما فعلناه في فلوريدا وما
يقومون به وضرائب
وصل
اتصال
[موسيقى]
لم يحصل عليه احد وهو انك فزت باصواتي كل
المناطق الحدوديه
بكجات واتساب
الولايات التي تشهد كل ما يحدث لا يمكن ان
نقبل بما يجري نحن بحاجه لرؤيه ونجاح ولا
نتنازل حتى نحقق اعلى اهداف
من ذي قبل نستطيع فعلا ذلك
اعور
كبيره
وجراه وطموح لاحلام امريكا نحن بحاجه
لاحلى من كبيره
لا نريد
[موسيقى]
قوتنا
للرفع مستوى
العاملين في امريكا واستعاده نسيج هذه
الامه
الديمقراطيين المتطرفين نشروا
جديده في الحكم لكن فكره ان هي مبنيه على
الحريه والمسؤوليه
وان يكون هناك منطق
[تصفيق]
ديسكرايب
الاقتصاد الامريكي وبنجاح الناس نبني افضل
الاقتصاد
وسنقوم بذلك بسرعه سربني افضل الاقتصاد
يشهده
واذا كنتم تذكرون
في اعقابها
ودور جامد
مره ثانيه ولكن سيكون بشكل اكبر
واقوى من اي
فتره سبقت
الامور
الجميله في الاستفتاءات
بل العوامل المهمه
سيكون اسهل علينا فعله
[تصفيق]
اللهم اللهم
ونعيده الى المستوى السابق وهو الصفر
افضل الارقام هو واحد بالمئه لا نريده
صفرا عن
وصلنا الى واحد
الى اثنين
المانيا
الدولار الاعلى
وعندما تراجع الدولار
تخسرنا الكثير
مع قيادات الدول
وتخفيض
ولكن هذه مساله مهمه من الصعب
عندما يقومون بذلك
ان
يدفع ثمن باهظا عندما يقومون بتخفيض
العمله
كانوا يصدقونني وكانوا يرفعون اثار
من وضع امريكا
سنعيد امريكا لتكون الاول
امريكا كل سياسه
جزيل الشكر لكم كلنا نحب وطننا وهذا هو ما
يجمعنا لست
بحاجه لهدف في حياتي كانت
بسيطه
وسهله
لكننا بنحبنا لوطننا نحن بحاجه لان نتدخل
هذا الوطن
لحمايه العامل الامريكي والاسره الامريكيه
والمشاريع التي تمكن امتنا منك تنافس
الدولي الذي لم يكن سابقا حتى اتيت الى
المنصب والان
خسرنا ذلك لانهم يعودون الى الصين والدول
الاخرى
يعني
تخفيض الضريبه
الان
كل الدول
وزوز
8 10 ملكا
قلت له انك لا تنسى ان تفعل ذلك
الصين
[تصفيق]
عندما يحدث ذلك
كم يعني
مهمه جدا سترورون
وايضا
سيعاد تنظيف
القوانين كي تعود امتنا من للازدهار كما
يجب
اييي المانيا جربت
عندما ارسلته
لا احد يتذكرها
ارسلته
لها
الرايه البيضاء
من روسيا وهذا ليس بامر جيد لالمانيا
ويكفيهم كل الامور التي يرقبونها
في البيئه
القومي لذلك
[تصفيق]
يا قلبي
عيد الشكر لن نحصل على الديك الرومي بسبب
بقى ارتفاع التكاليف همم
لكننا في اداره ترامب صناعيد اكثر واو
والصحه والنجاح للطبقه الوسطى ولا امريكا
باكملها
همم ارجو ان تجلسوا فاشعر بذنب كبير وانتم
تقطفون
همم تقرفون طول هذا الوقت
اشعر بذنب كبير ولا اريد ان يحدث هذا ولكل
اسره
واعامل
يعانون
الان هذه الحمله ستكون لكم
المساعده في طريقها اليكم
دمر حدودنا ولكننا سنعيد تامينها كما
فعلنا بنينا الجدار والان اليه
الانتخابات
كان امامنا ثلاث اسابيع لكنهم قالوا ان لم
يفعلوا ذلك وعندما عندها ادراك انهم
يريدون هذه الكارثه كارثه الحدود
الاسباب التي جعلتنا ناجحين في الحدود هي
حقيقه امرين